What's poppin now as you can see I'm wearing some
Warrior swag cuz you know I love baseball. What can I say and you know Steph Curry? She's great. She's amazing
today We're gonna be talking about LinkedIn
And I'm gonna be talking about how to get an internship at LinkedIn as a software engineer now before you watch this video
I think you should watch the first one and the second one that I made because I talked about how I caught my first internship
And then I talked about how I got my internship at Citadel which actually kind of feeds into how I got this internship
Because with that experience alright so without further ado here we go
Now before we talk about how I got the internship let me just talk to you about the benefit
When I interned there the salary was
$45 an hour or seven point eight thousand dollars a month, so it was the same asset though
But the housing was less good
So this time we had to share a two-bedroom apartment with four people so it was two people in one room
Now at first. I thought that was like kind of ugghh..
But I mean soon. I realized like because of that we were a lot closer
So like always you know like every other big company. There's free breakfasts free lunch and free dinner
You know their breakfast was bomb honestly
I think out of all my internships their breakfast was the best because you get smoked salmon every day
Not like other companies that sometimes. They either don't have smoked salmon or they only have smoked salmon Fridays
And of course I have a gym, but that's a given all right so now that you know. That's a pretty dope job
Let me tell you how I got it or how you can get it
So let's just look at my resume real quick all right
So here's my resume now as you can see the work experience has been updated from last time this time
I have two jobs. I have Citadel and Scotiabank now for the Citadel one
I want to talk about you know my C++
Experience is you know talking about writing hyper format multi-threaded WebSocket server
Yeah
So you got to add these kind of keywords because you know honestly the recruiters they
just you know look for keywords and see if you look technical not because
They are the ones that are gonna do a first pass on your resume
And if you can't pass them then you're not gonna get an interview and sometimes not gonna lie you're not going to read everything
They're just gonna be scanning for keywords so make sure you add as much jargon as possible
But also you know be truthful so yeah so under projects
I didn't add that much, but I did do extra things like I did a lot of web projects
I actually did also a hack the north competition where I won to be honest. I don't think that really matters
I don't think they even checked that they mostly care about my Citadel experience. The other stuffs are just bonus oh
My god, and I just remember when I was at Citadel
I actually learned a lot because I also did a lot of side projects hmm
Maybe not a lot of side project. I did one side project and it was actually a
Adult video streaming site
And don't ask me why I wanted to do that okay fine. You can ask me
It's because I thought there was a lot of potential in that market
And I thought it was the best way to penetrate it using a very good tech
But I did learn a lot from building those projects like for example. I learned full stack development
I learned about you know how to use AWS
Ether easy to s3 storage see the ends like the whole stack to make a video streaming site, and it was pretty fast
But I realized it was kind of costly so then I decided to shut it down so yeah
So using that resume I applied it everywhere, and then I started interviewing let me just show you like a quick
Snapshot of all the jobs that I got offered
So so I once again, I got ten interviews it seems like every term
I just get ten interviews, but and then I get about let's see one two three four five five offers and one ranked
Yeah, so I got rejected by you know Amazon Google
Microsoft really oh
This is for embedded cell for engineering and then pound tear technology
Not gonna lie LinkedIn was not my first choice
You know I would rather go to Google or Palantir. You know then LinkedIn, but
You know c'est la vie, so yeah as you can see forty offers. I had course Sarah as a software engineer infrastructure, LinkedIn
Microsoft as a software engineer
tinder
Yelp, and I was ranked for yext so that is pretty funny. There's a funny story about tinder um
Not sure if I should get into it, but if ever if I got edited this out. I'll just put it in the patreon page
All right, so let's talk about the interview process
For LinkedIn so because I went to Waterloo and I was in the job mine system
It was a lot easier all I had to do was to on-site interview
And if people came to campus for that you would do one interview
And then you would have a dinner together with all the candidates
And then the day after if you pass the first interview you're gonna get the second interview
So let's talk about the first interview so the first interview my question was given a set of non-negative
Integers and a value some determine if there is a subset of the given set with some equal to given some for example
You have a set
334 for
12 5 2 and
Then the sum that they want is 9 and the way the output would be would be true and then that subset would be 4
& 5 because if you add them together you get 9 so easy
dynamic programming
So simple I mean if you want to solve it
You know you could just you could just tell me what the answer is on a comment
I'll just pin it and yeah there you go. I mean you could probably just google it and find and figure that out
I'm not gonna lie. I hadn't memorized
Like I already knew about that problem before he asked me and I just pretend that I didn't know I was like oh
Damn, what should I use and then first I used the recursive version because that's like the naive version
And I'm like wait a minute I could do it faster, and then I did the dynamic programming version, but yeah
It was all rehearsed for me, so it was great now the second interview the second interview was less of a coding interview
It's more of an infrastructure
And I think it depends what you specialize
In and then they would give you different interviews depending on that so let me tell you what a question is
You see the question asks you to design a fast key value store
And it needs to support the function get and put just like all key value stores and all the keys would fit in memory
But the values would be too large
So you can't fit the whole thing your whole key value store in
memory because that would be too big and you have two primitives you have a
look up structure so can't like a hash-table and then also an
Append-only file system basically the whole point of this question is for you to think of a creative way to use
the memory hash map and
the file system
to be able to implement this key value store in essence what you have to do is you have to put the keys in the
memory hash map and then the values of the memory hash map would actually be the file number and
The offset and then the actual value you're going to append that into a file
And then you use the value of the hash map which is the offset and the file number?
To actually get the real value in your file system now the main constraint in this question is that in the file system
It's append-only so when you write to a file you can only append to it that means you cannot do random writes
But you could do random reads meaning you can choose an offset, and then just read that value
But you can't do that right so that's the question. I'm not gonna go over it
If I do or if people really want the answer I'll just put it on my patreon page all right so now
I'm gonna talk about how it was working there now. Let's talk about the work first
Let me just tell you that it was pretty chill. I would come in at like 11:00 a.m.
And then leave out like maybe 6:00 p.m.
Not even there's not as much pressure
At LinkedIn then for example Facebook or Citadel so what I did when I was there
I was on the graph team we wanted to make a whole new
In-memory graph database so it was a lot faster now what that graph database is supposed to do is supposed to be the back end
Of all the queries that you do on LinkedIn so for example
Facebook does it well
But basically what we wanted to do is that we want to allow users to be able to type queries like
Friends of friends who never worked at Microsoft, but worked at Facebook, so this was like a new project
Written from scratch and then the thing is the whole code base was in C++. So usually LinkedIn is like a Java shop
But just for this project it was in C++
Because it's a high-performance, and we could do a lot more low-level things a lot easier, so it's pretty cool
I did learn a lot about databases, and you know because we had to write everything from scratch like
Optimizers, you know the query engine query persistence and stuff like that. I worked on something very little which was a query persistence
it's just using the graph database to persist all the queries and
I don't remember clearly why I had to do that. I remember there was a reason, but I kind of forgot
But but in the end I just grabbed it to be honest like all of my effort
It was it was pretty useless so I got a return offer. I was pretty happy about that
unfortunately, I did not return and
What I liked the most was more the social side of LinkedIn so during my term
It was it was winter term and all of the interns came from University of Waterloo
We were nine interns eight of us stayed in two apartments
And they were next to each other so we would hang out all the time it was so fun
We would play Avalon like almost every night, and it was a good bonding experience and like yeah
it was the best internship because I built like long lasting friends, and I still talked to some of them now and
Yeah, I really appreciate that and I even made like kinda like a souvenir video
It's kind of like a collage of what we did. I mean I get I guess I guess I could show you a few clips
It's pretty funny cuz
Cuz in some ways that's kind of what?
What made me start making videos?
You know after making this collage. I kind of just made more and more videos made more more collages and then in the end
Like this is where I am now. I make your videos for you guys
Let's see I remembered this video was really cheesy
Let me skip to that part
But I realized yeah
That for the first time in my life that not a single day have I ever felt
Oh
Yeah, and this song was so popular back then cuz Fast Five was it Fast Five no no sorry
I think it was fast and furious seven just came out and
Or was it fast flying. I don't know but basically the main actor died in yeah, I used this song
Yeah, so these are all my injured friends
This was Great America hang out there for a while was real fun. I
Live with this guy actually I roomed with this guy we were in the same room. Yeah, this guy works at snapchat now, I think
Anyways enough of that
Alright, so I think that's about it. I hope that was useful for you
I hope you know that was enjoyable now if it was don't forget to press the like button and also if you're not subscribed subscribe
And also don't forget to press the bell so that you'll be notified when the next video comes out and the next video
After this would be a video about Facebook, but yeah, thanks again peace